Okay, let's see how you answered. These two questions were actually a technique
that's called the door-in-the-face technique. Here, a person will ask for a
larger request that is most likely a bit over the top, and then when the result
is no, they ask for a smaller request. Here's an example I experienced
personally. When I was in graduate school and on a limited budget, I received a
phone call from a firefighter's association looking to raise money for
firefighters and their families. I was a big supporter of the firefighters.
However, the person asked if I could donate $100. And I actually did not have
$100 available to donate. And I told them sorry, that that was too much. And
immediately the person said, oh well, can you perhaps give $15? And right away
I said sure, I can give $15. And the idea here again is that this was a
technique called the door-in-the-face, and it's actually quite effective.
Asking for something that is large and maybe not typical, a person's likely to
say no. When you followup with a more reasonable request, a person is typically
more likely to respond positively. Can you think of any personal experiences
with these two techniques that we discussed? Perhaps you can share them on the
forum.